[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they really have a quarterback
controversy in philadelphia which is
where we start
with peter king from good morning
football football morning in america i'm
gonna get it right pete
i've got good morning football football
morning in america monday morning
football
i apologize football morning problem dan
hey dan listen
i don't i don't think the eagles have a
quarterback controversy
what's the controversy play jalen hurts
seriously okay i thought that was the
funniest thing of the weekend when doug
peterson said after the game
and again this morning on wip oh i
really haven't decided or i haven't made
up my mind
doug let me tell you something you're
not going you're not going to be allowed
on the team
plane to phoenix on saturday
if you say that carson wentz is your
quarterback sunday
in glendale arizona here is doug
peterson and he won't commit to
who his starter is is jalen your starter
next week and if so
what will the challenge be you know now
that more tape is out on him
i'm gonna uh enjoy this one i'm gonna go
home and
relax and be with my family tonight and
enjoy this win and get ready for the
week
oh you know you have all this momentum
you're feeling good
i don't know maybe this is gamesmanship
pete maybe he doesn't want to let
arizona know that they might have to get
ready for a running quarterback
dan arizona knows arizona knows jalen
hurts his playing it's just that
everybody in the philadelphia eagles
organization players coaches
are walking on eggshells with carson
wentz i mean seriously if i'm carson
wentz today
you can't go in the facility but i'll do
a phone call with uh
because monday and tuesday facilities
are closed
around the league but i do a phone call
with uh
with doug peterson and said you know
stop being maniacally concerned with my
feelings i'm not a pain of glass
i understand this guy played great you
got to play him good let's go and win
and he i don't know whether he's going
to do that or whether he would do that
but
the rest of this i don't know there was
such this is the biggest win this team
has had
in a year yeah and it was
almost like they tied
did you see i mean where was the emotion
and uh yeah
yeah baby oh we we're back in it
if we win this week and washington loses
we're a half game out of first place and
washington's coming to our place
in week 17. hey look
they're trying to be respect respectful
to carson wentz
i i appreciate that but you know it's
you got to play this kid the rest of the
way and see what you have
what kind of trade market is there will
there be for carson wentz
i think i will be surprised if
the indianapolis colts are not
interested in him and to what degree i
don't know
it's hard for me to say what his value
would be would it be
a low one would it be two twos
i don't know you know in the quarterback
business dan and again i am not
comparing him at all to josh rosen
but josh rosen was drafted number 10 one
year
and then he was traded for the 45th pick
11 months later
you know so it's like the new car you
drive it off the lot
it loses 20 of its value so
i i don't know but the most important
thing
if i'm carson once if
at the end of this year i realize that
it's over
in philly and if i'm him i'm probably
hoping that it
is because it's just it's going to be
too hard
but but whatever if at the end of the
year that
it appears that it's over if i'm carson
once particularly when the cap
is most likely going down significantly
and if it isn't it's certainly not going
up
i would be as good as i could to the
acquiring team and to the eagles
to try to make it happen he's peter king
football morning in america
it's must read every monday morning
recapping what happened over the weekend
in the nfl
watching the steelers last night i
was not surprised what i saw with
buffalo but
i'm starting to have more and more
questions about a team that only has two
losses this year if you were going to
describe the steelers to somebody who
didn't watch them last night
how would you describe them i i mean i
hate to be cliche but quite honestly
peaked too soon okay
and dan people are talking about this
running game well they got to get the
running game going
dan over the last two
months this team has rushed for 54 yards
per game
that's not two weeks that's seven
games yeah and so this is not
something you know i saw that and and i
assume it's true but i heard it uh on
one of the shows over the weekend
that mike tomlin put his team in pads on
friday and
now he's getting serious they're gonna
get the running game going
i mean good for tomlin for doing that
really honestly
but you know it's gonna take more than
the show of putting his team in pads
uh to become a good running team they're
not a good running team uh
and that really exposes the most
interesting thing
that uh that uh ben roethlisberger said
in what i thought was a very honest
post-game press conference he said we
need to be
to do better at being a more balanced
offense
defense plays pass if you can't run the
ball
okay so you combine that with the
leading
team in the nfl in drops and tell me
what can the steelers do well on offense
now
you simply cannot ask your defense to
hold teams
to the level of the 76 steelers to say
okay you got to hold everybody to 12
points a game
or whatever that was it was absurd that
year but
you can't do that in modern football and
so that's why
this is not in my opinion it's not just
a slump with the steelers look they're
lucky
they go to cincinnati on sunday they'll
get a little bit well
but the fact is this team has to play
the colts
in week 16 and has to play in
cleveland in week 17 in a game they
might need
as absurd as it is they have gone from a
98
chance in seven days a 98 chance to win
their division
to if if cleveland wins tonight it's an
81
chance also factoring in with that
defense
losing devon bush and bud dupree so it
was a formidable defense but you're
losing
two of their three biggest impact
players or you know two of their four
uh the game tonight you mentioned the
ravens and the browns
how big a game is this well
i mean you know look the crazy thing is
even though you don't want it to happen
the browns can afford
to lose this game and they're still
probably going to be a wild card team
but this is as close to a must game as
you can get for baltimore
if baltimore wants to make the playoffs
now baltimore could lose and win the
last two games and probably get in
but still the ravens just have to start
playing well dan
i mean they have been so disjointed all
year
this is a game for the baltimore ravens
about playing well and getting momentum
if they want to make anything of their
season
with what we've seen with aaron rodgers
and the packers they're just sort of
hanging around hanging around
i think they're unbelievable yeah i
really do i
and look i don't i didn't mean to
interrupt your question but
the more i think of what we're seeing in
the packers
so dan i had an item in my column this
morning
about how you know i was like so many
people this off season all right
and i said okay the packers are not
going 13-3 again
you know they're just they've got too
many flaws and they didn't do a thing
about their receiver position
and i'm not saying i thought they were a
fluke last year i didn't but
i just thought they would come down to
earth a little bit
so now they're on track to have the
exact same record as last year
and here's the amazing thing that i
wrote my column that
if you look at since matt lafleur
walked onto campus in green bay
regular season and postseason best
records in football
andy reed 27 and five matt lefleur
24-7 he's second and
so i mean what we're seeing now is a
program and as long as aaron rodgers is
there
he's just the magic man and as long as
aaron rodgers is there i think
that he and matt lafleur have potential
to make beautiful music and i think
aaron rodgers
after the game last night dan i thought
he said something really smart that i
didn't even realize
i didn't know that since he's been there
they've never had home field through the
playoffs
and they really want that fans are no
fans
they want teams coming in to green bay
on uh january 17th and on january 24th
in fact i think they would love it if it
was a prime time game on that divisional
weekend
just so that it would be colder and
hopefully the wind would be blowing
sideways
well also you want to get a warm weather
team tampa maybe on the road the saints
dome team get them on the road as well
um
if arizona you know whoever it might be
who's going to go there
and i know we love to do a referendum
every monday on mvp
and as much as i've said it was patrick
mahomes mahomes looked
mortal yesterday and i still go back
and i i still believe it there's nobody
who's made the position look easier than
aaron rodgers
to me in the history of the game he can
make it look
easier than anybody that doesn't mean
he's the mvp
but it feels like you know
it's starting to lean a little bit more
that way with uh what you've seen with
aaron rodgers
if you were voting like the criteria you
would have for mvp
is what pete i think
it's the guy who is most invaluable to
his team
that's what i think it is that's what
the most valuable player
says to me and hey dan
i'll i'll you know i've thought about
this a lot and i thought about it for
a good 15 minutes last night i in my
office around
one in the morning and i really just
thought
what did i want to say about the mvp
uh this morning because we're getting to
the point
uh where you're gonna have to make a
decision three weeks from now
and i wrote i think the mvp is pretty
close to a holmes rogers toss-up
and that's how i see it i think it's
it's the
mvp is going to be one in the last three
weeks of the season
yeah it's it's i don't think you can go
wrong with either one of those guys i
was also wondering about defensive
player of the year
i mean tj watt could win it but the most
valuable defensive player in the game is
aaron donald
no aaron donald and the other guy i'll
tell you what dan
that and and i i look i'd have a better
argument for this if miami won the game
but they didn't but
xavier howard is playing the position of
cornerback the way stephon gilmore
played it last year
and gilmore won defensive player of the
year last year
now i am with you i i think one of the
most amazing things
about aaron donald is most of the time
he's an interior defensive lineman
getting stuck in traffic having a having
a cluttered path to the quarterback at
all times
dan in the last 45 games he's got 45 and
a half sacks
i mean that just doesn't happen but how
many people have you covered pete where
i said he disrupts an entire offense t.j
watt i have to account for him
yeah i mean jj at his peak was great but
you know i go back to lawrence taylor i
don't know jj watt i'll tell you this
dan i i j.j watt and aaron donald
are similarly disruptive i am i'm not
going to sit here and say aaron donald's
better than j.j watted his prime i mean
in his prime he had some of the greatest
games a defensive player has ever had
so and again if aaron donald does it
longer
than j.j watt did then i'll take my hat
off to him but think of this dan
this is this the the the defensive
player of the year
award is 50 years old this year
okay no one has ever won it more than
three times
lawrence taylor won it three times j.j
watt won it three times
aaron donald if he wins this year that
would be his third win he'd be
29 years old after seven years in the
nfl
i think that i i mean you know if you go
to vegas and bet what are the odds he's
gonna win a fourth one
put me on the on the over uh i'll take
more than three
let's just say that we asked this uh
last week
i think paulie or mclovin brought it up
that if you could start your defense
with
any player in history and uh
and i i just said lawrence taylor was
something i had never seen i still
haven't seen lawrence taylor
uh like somebody who can emulate what he
does
you know me and joe green and reggie
white and you know we can go down the
list of
dion was wonderful lawrence taylor i saw
fear i saw fear on a football
field when lawrence taylor was going in
to sac
ken o'brien in a preseason game i truly
saw
fear i i would start with lawrence
taylor
um i who would be your pick
i'll tell you lawrence taylor uh i would
i would have a nod to deacon jones but
that was a
that was a different time a different
era the head slap
the all the other stuff you could do
way back when um dick butkus is a middle
linebacker had 18 sacks in a season
he was unbelievably good but
i think in today's game i would take the
interior disrupter
oh okay and because i think the interior
disrupter
is so much harder to find than anybody
else even though i agree with you hey
dan
the great thing about lawrence taylor in
my opinion
is that when he was hurt he would do
things i saw him play with a torn
pectoral
which is impossible with his arm wrapped
up you know on his chest like with a
huge ace bandage
and i saw him better than new orleans
saints in the superdome one night he
look this guy this guy was just not
normal
and i i have great admiration for that's
a tough question i'd have to think about
it but
i think i take the internal disruptor
like
uh like in aaron donald great stuff as
always pete the column is must read it's
monday morning quarterback
you did it again you did it again but
that's okay dan
i love you and hey monday morning
quarterback
is where it all began that's true and i
did it for 21 years
and it was the great time of my life
it still is but football morning in
america and dan one last thing yes
i do want to tell you please take five
minutes today
to read my the section of my column
about contact tracing
and how i believe anyway it's kind of
saving the nfl season
nbcsports.com football morning in
america thank you pete as always
okay all the best dan take care